[Musique]
bonjour le costume du petit bonjour
jimmy bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bonjour pascal ça fâche bonjour à vous
vous êtes professeur des univers à
l'université des antilles professeur des
universités la spécialité aménagement et
environnement nous parlons aujourd'hui
du risque volcanique à l'occasion des
cent vingtième anniversaire de
l'éruption du 8 mai 1902 une éruption
qui a provoqué un chamboulement dans
l'aménagement de notre territoire
puisque fort de france est devenue la
capitale et puis d'autres quartiers ont
été créés dans plusieurs communes de ce
notre île aujourd'hui ces trente mille
personnes environ qui sont directement
exposés au risque volcanique en
martinique qui représente moins d'un
habitant sur dix mais la question qui se
pose c'est leur logement comment reloger
les personnes évacuées alors que nous
savons très bien que le centre et le sud
sont déjà totalement saturé mais écoutez
là ça c'est une vraie vraie vraie
question là on est on est au coeur du
problème c'est vrai que l'aménagement du
territoire c'est si j'ose dire c'est
vraiment là comment dirais-je la
discipline qui demain va devenir la
discipline phare et pour les politiques
c'est véritablement la question centrale
parce que tout passe par l'aménagement
du territoire maintenant très
honnêtement à cette question je n'ai pas
de je n'ai pas de réponse parce que il
n'y a pas une réponse il y a des
réponses et 6 réponses elles ne doivent
absolument pas être celle des experts ou
celle des politiques ou celle des
socioprofessionnels 7 ses réponses se
sont si vous voulez tout le monde doit
contribuer à la réflexion et je moi moi
j'en appelle véritablement à un
véritable plan marshall si vous voulez
de l'aménagement en martinique parce
qu'il faut revoir et repenser totalement
l'aménagement alors là nous parlons de
risque volcanique oui il faut revoir
l'aménagement à si vous voulez un peu à
en raison de du risque volcanique main
raison de la gestion des risques en
martinique c'est vrai que la martinique
est exposé à l'ensemble des risques
naturels majeurs en en dehors de
l'avalanche mais justement parce que
nous sommes un petit territoire un
territoire qui fait 70 km de long 30 km
de large avec une très forte densité de
population
un territoire qui est extrêmement
contraint parce qu'il est vallonné
montagneux il est il est comment
dirais-je soumis à l'inondation il est
soumis au séisme il est soumis au
volcanisme il est soumis aux ouragans il
est soumis ce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle
le risque six autres hop c'est à dire la
liquéfaction des sols et donc la
question se pose de savoir où le calysto
les populations et je ne parle même pas
de changement climatique avec
l'élévation du niveau de la mer et donc
il faut véritablement qu'il y ait une
sorte de task force si j'ose dire c'est
à dire un regroupement d'experts mais
qui soit à la fois des politiques d des
géographes des des économistes des
sociologues des anthropologues des
architectes qui qui se réunissent pour
penser l'aménagement
mais ce qui veut dire parce qu'elle
sache que malgré l'existence des plans
de prévention des risques naturels on
n'a pas véritablement intégrée notamment
les aléas et notamment le risque
volcanique alors qu'un autre façon
d'occuper le territoire les plans les
pleins exister les plans ont ceci de
particulier c'est qu'il permette au
moins au maire d' éviter si vous voulez
des secteurs qui aurait pu être
extrêmement problématique pour les
populations mais aujourd'hui nous nous
apercevons que le territoire comme je le
disais extrêmement petit est contraint
et qu'il faut véritablement repenser
l'aménagement quel est le véritable
problème pendant des décennies nous
avons aménagé ce territoire au coup par
coup par à-coups c'est à dire
franchement j'ai envie de dire au
feeling mais il ne s'agissait ni de
pointe et quiconque 1 l'objectif c'est
notre histoire qu'il veut nous avons la
martinique est un pays qui a une
histoire extrêmement jeune depuis la
départementalisation à 46 on a fait
comme on a pu mais sauf que revenons-en
aux classiques aménagé s'est organisée
de façon raisonnée des activités sur un
espace donné et je dis bien raisonné
raisonnée ça veut dire qu'il faut penser
la chose et c'est comment concilier
développement et prévention des risques
c'est bien ça mais c'est surtout moi je
dois dire que je compte énormément sur
le sahara le schéma d'aménagement
régional qui doit être revue révisé par
là par la ctm parce que ce schéma
d'aménagement régional va véritablement
donné si vous voulez un cap une
direction pour l'aménagement mais vous
avez raison il faut arriver à concilier
les deux c'est à dire il ne s'agit pas
de d'aménager le territoire en se disant
on protège les populations et on oublie
qu'il ya qui a dû développement
économique il faut arriver à
avant ces deux concerts mais c'est un
exercice qui est extrêmement complexe et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'en
appelle à une vision véritablement
collective qui ne soit pas la vision
soit d'un parti d'une entité watts mais
qui soit une vision vraiment
martiniquaise globale pour que tout un
chacun puisse non seulement participer
mais en bénéficier alors prenons
l'exemple de la commune du prêcheur une
commune exposée à plusieurs années a en
même temps les l'art les coulées de boue
mais aussi l'érosion du littoral le
risque de rouler de submersion et la
municipalité a choisi de grosses
construire une sorte d'école refuge
pensez vous que ce soit la solution pour
les autres communes exposées au risque
volcanique j'ai alors c'est vrai que le
prêcheur a toujours été un peu à la
pointe à ce niveau en matière de
résilience de gestion du risque est-ce
que la l'école et cette école refuge
celle la solution en fait il n'y a pas
de style n'y a pas une solution c'est
une solution une solution parmi d'autres
mais c'est vrai que en matière de
gestion des risques naturels et en
matière de résilience des populations
il faut qu'il y ait plusieurs solutions
celle-ci en est une c'est une sûrement
une très bonne solution le fait de
relocaliser les populations plus haut
dans les terres c'est une des solutions
alors ça permet de lutter contre
l'érosion côtière ça permet de lutter
contre les all cyclonique ça permet en
effet de lutter contre les l'art mais ça
permettra pas forcément de lutter contre
par exemple risque sismique ou contre
d'éventuelles nuées ardentes ou etc des
exemples dans d'autres pays qui
pourraient nous nous inspirer pour nous
chez nous oui bien sûr il y à des pays
bas il suffit de prendre si vous voulez
des pays hier j'étais avec des
une façon ce sont des dans le cadre d'un
projet erasmus il ya des enseignants
étrangers qui sont en martinique et il
dit je discutais avec un enseignant
italien qui justement me disais comment
sur l'espace qu'ils occupent ils sont
soumis eux aussi au risque au risque
comment dirais-je volcanique et comment
il les a il tente quand même de
concilier développement économique et en
même temps protection des populations
extrêmement complexe mais ce que moi ce
que j'ai trouvé intéressant dans ce
qu'il me disait c'est le fait que il
faut garder espoir et que de toute façon
la vie doit continuer coûte que coûte en
dépit du fait que ils savent qu'ils ont
une épée de damoclès sur la tête mais la
vie doit de toute façon continuer à
s'imposer alors une autre problématique
c'est la forte dépendance de notre île à
la montagne pelée pour les ressources en
eau près de 60% des captages sont
réalisés dans le nord alimentant le
centre et le sud de l'île at on déjà
prévu de solution entre la pénurie après
un aléa volcaniques alors après un aléa
volcanique j'aurais du mal à vous
répondre parce qu'à ma connaissance je
ne suis pas convaincu qu'il existe qu'il
existe véritablement des solutions à ce
niveau mais ceci dit la problématique
aller encore plus large parce que on
parle de plus en plus de changements
climatiques et on pas enfin les les
simulations indiquent que nous aurons
des carême de plus en plus sec des idées
hivernage aussi de plus en plus humide
mais des carême plus sec ce qui veut
dire qu'il y aura potentiellement des
pénuries d'eau et pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas encore de solution miracle
pour ce pour trouver des bras pour pour
régler ce problème il faudrait imaginer
alors il ya le barrage de lamaze oki en
effet permet aux agriculteurs donc de
diriger leurs champs mais il faudrait
penser dans les années à venir à
d'autres retenues collinaires donc où
les positionner parce que bien entendu à
partir du moment où vous avez des
retenues collinaires de grands volumes
ça veut dire ce sont des espaces qui
sont qui ne sont pas utilisés pour
recevoir le logement des populations
pour pour le développement économique et
c'est donc là encore vous voyez on est
au coeur de la problématique de
l'aménagement du territoire et je répète
l'aménagement du territoire nécessite un
véritable plan marshall en martinique il
faut véritablement non seulement il il
faut avoir des dessous des fonds pour
permettre un bon aménagement du
territoire mais il faut véritablement
que nos élus nos politiques s'entoure
d'experts et je suis pas en train de
prêcher pour ma paroisse parce que pour
moi les experts c'est pas ce ne sont pas
des géographes ou les aménageurs c'est
véritablement tout un panel de
compétences qui permettent d'avoir une
vision pour ce territoire alors il ya un
secteur qui est fortement dépendant de
cette zone volcanique c'est le secteur
agricole que c'est quand même 14 % de la
surface la surface agricole utile
interdite est ce que les plans de
prévention des risques naturels
interdisent toute construction où toutes
sortes d'activités dans les zones à fort
risque volcanique alors d'un mot ça
fonctionne dans les zones qui sont de
toutes façons les plus exposés c'est à
dire dans les zones que qui sont eux
représentés par la couleur rouge sur les
plans d'exposition rite bien évidemment
qu'il n'y a interdiction de construire
et de développer la moindre activité et
puis plus on s'éloigne si vous voulez du
risque et plus la tolérance et devient
certaine tolérance ce qui est quand même
intéressant dans le cas du risque
volcanique si j'ose dire c'est que
autant le volcan apporte la mort puisque
on l'a bien vu en 1910 on l'a bien vu en
1929 mais autant les versants des
volcans volcaniques ce qu'on appelle les
planètes sont extrêmement riches fertile
et donc permettre la vie et donc c'est
de cette espèce de l'ambivalence de
dichotomie qu'il ya entre la vie et la
mort qu'il qu'il faut arriver qu'il faut
arriver à gérer mais sur un territoire
aussi contraint que le nôtre il faut
véritablement trouver
j'ai envie de dire un équilibre alors
cet équilibre certain dans certaines
communes il y à vraiment des réflexions
autour de la question puis dans d'autres
communes on a un peu le sentiment qu'on
qu'on redécouvre que la martinique est
volcanique ou que la martinique est
soumise à des risques plus il alerte
jaune un petit peu remis les pendules à
l'heure il y a un an alors l alerte
l'alertent jeunes le classement de la
montagne pelée c'est en vigilance jaune
ça a remis un peu les pendules à l'heure
mais ce qui est quand même surprenant
c'est que on est une partie de la
population qui a re découvert à cette
occasion qu'il y avait un volcan en
martinique je rappelle quand même que la
montagne pelée c'est le troisième volte
face et c'est les redditions meurtri
c'est la troisième éruption la plus
meurtrière à l'échelle humaine
après le tambour haye après le krakatoa
29 mille morts donc lamartine on ne peut
pas re découvrir qu'on a un volcan
martinique la martinique est une île qui
est un volcan extrêmement majestueux un
volcan qui est d'une violence inouïe et
ce volcan il faut vraiment le respecter
le respecter au sens où il faut tout
faire pour protéger les populations et
c'est pour ça que ce que vous évoquez
tout à l'heure cette école refuge c'est
bien c'est même très bien ça doit être
salué mais c'est une solution parmi
d'autres il en faudrait d'autres une
dernière question après l'éruption de
1902 on avait préconisé de faire de la
zone volcanique un territoire totalement
inhabitée la proposition avait été
renouvelé en 1929 avec l'abandon
définitif des communes de saint pierre
du prêcheur et du morne rouge qui avait
été recommandé pensez vous que cette
stratégie est applicable sur un
territoire insulaire nom déjà sur un
territoire insulaire c'est très
difficile sur un territoire aussi petit
clown hop c'est juste impossible à mon
avis il faut apprendre à vivre avec le
risque c'est ça aussi la résilience et
apprendre à vivre avec le risque comme
il nous faudra à mon avis sûrement
apprendre à vivre avec avec l'aco vide
je pense que nous ne pouvons pas à
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème fuir le
problème il faut il faut essayer de leur
de le gérer de le dominer si tant est
qu'il soit deux minables en tout cas
apprendre à vivre avec et donc
développer des solutions nous permettant
de baies de fuir lorsqu'il le faut et
donc ça ça pose vraiment la question
aussi de la formation des populations et
de l'information des populations merci
beaucoup pascal sa femme